[Music]
on this monday night changing military
culture and conduct
the blistering new report and
recommendations together we will deliver
reforms that stand the test of time
but will the promises be met with
political will
new gun laws in canada as we see gun
violence continue to rise
it is our duty to keep taking action the
boldest suite of proposed actions to
control access to firearms in this
country
and honoring the children taken in the
texas mouse shooting the first emotional
wake for one of the 21 victims begins
today
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight nintu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
two big stories out of the nation's
capital today including new proposed gun
laws more on that in a moment but first
a highly anticipated report into sexual
misconduct in canada's military is out
with 403 pages and 48 recommendations
the report details a culture that has
entrenched abuses of power it comes a
year after a review formally started
following allegations against senior
leaders in the canadian forces first
brought to light by global news while
the government is short on details and
timelines there are promises for a
better path forward mercedes stephenson
has our top story tonight
madame luis arbour has seen her share of
disturbing material as a former supreme
court justice and a war crimes
investigator but what she heard
interviewing women in the canadian armed
forces still shocked her day in day out
stories of
young women being told
appalling things like
you know young recruits being told well
you should get on the pill arbor says
the military is an insular and outdated
institution that will not change on its
own maybe the most striking feature was
that this kind of allergy to anything
that is not from inside that
community tight-knit
homogeneous they were uniforms they're
all alike they aspire to all be alike
when the canadian armed forces found
itself in the headlines arbor said it
would scramble into a hyperactive
reaction to appear to be doing something
new titles public pronouncements and
powerpoint slides rather than tackling
the root of the problems cultural and
structural issues that have enabled
toxic power dynamics and bad behavior
including sexual misconduct to go
unpunished a situation arbor says puts
some members of the canadian military at
more risk from their comrades than the
enemy a liability she says for canada if
our people can't feel safe if if they
can't if we can't attract and retain
talent from all segments of canadian
society we are going to fail canada
arbor's report listed dozens of
recommendations that would bring
profound change to the military
including permanently moving all
criminal sexual offenses to the civilian
justice system
changing the way senior officers are
promoted and arbor takes on the military
college system including royal military
college long seen as sacrosanct but she
says it perpetuates a don't get caught
mentality instead of teaching
accountability her assessment was that
these are a massive problem that the
culture in these institutions is a big
problem but survivors of sexual
misconduct say the details and funding
to support change are critical it's easy
enough to say that yes we need to do
that it's another matter of trying to
get the money to do that the key thing
here is what we're going to do with this
information how we're going to implement
it defense minister anita anand says
this time the government is serious
about culture change in this moment in
time
when the world appears to be growing
darker
we must grab the bull by the horns
and make these changes now
mercedes stevenson is joining us now and
mercedes after hearing these
recommendations and the minister's
response is there any reason to believe
things will change and be any different
this time around
well that's really the critical question
the minister says this is a different
team and that she has faith in them
there's also a political fire under this
government to do something about this
because of course it was under former
defense minister harjit sajin that
allegations against general vance were
first brought forward and the government
has been criticized for not doing enough
about that they also are self-declared
feminists which means there is a
political motivation for them to do
something they are looking at appointing
an external monitor one of the key
recommendations from justice arbor as
well who would report to the minister to
help keep track of this but at the end
of the day the question will be what the
politicians do and the interesting thing
to me about this report need to that's
different than other ones is that it
really focuses on putting that impetus
on the politicians and civilian
oversight to do something mercedes
stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes the prime minister was not at
that news conference about military
misconduct reform but he was at another
one promising to get tough on guns in
this country during a charged time in
the gun control debate in the wake of
the devastating mass school shooting in
texas canada's liberal government is
putting forward its boldest moves yet
late this afternoon the liberals tabled
new legislation abigail beeman has been
watching this story unfold and joins us
now with the latest abigail what is the
federal government proposing
to the hallmark of this plan is what the
liberals are calling a freeze rather
than a ban on handguns across the
country here's how the prime minister
describes it
we're introducing legislation to
implement
a national freeze
on handgun ownership
what this means is that it will no
longer be possible to buy
sell
transfer or import
handguns
anywhere in canada
in other words
we're capping the market for handguns
as a further part of this new
legislation we're also fighting guns
smuggling and trafficking by increasing
maximum criminal penalties and providing
more tools for law enforcement to
investigate firearm crimes
a freeze means the government is placing
big limits on who can actually buy and
sell handguns going forward the list
includes law enforcement and people who
need to carry guns for protection as
well as authorized sport shooting
athletes in addition to the handgun
freeze the liberals are promising to
increase maximum sentences for firearms
penalties and something called a new red
flag law aimed at helping victims of
domestic abuse that would allow courts
to require those considered a danger to
themselves or others to surrender
firearms now abigail the liberals have
long promised to take action without
seeing results commitments in both the
2019 and 2021 elections did not become
law so what's currently missing from
this legislation that the liberals
promised
well a big promise in the last two
elections was around amnesty a buy back
program for current gun owners details
are still trickling out here but it
doesn't appear there's anything in this
new legislation about speeding up the
buy back program and on the issue of
illegal guns the liberals say these
measures will help but it's not clear
how they'll stop guns illegally entering
the country a new stats can report which
noted an uptick in gun violence said
there's very little information
available on the source of firearms used
in crime particularly whether a gun was
stolen bought illegally or smuggled into
the country when we asked the prime
minister about this he didn't offer
specifics but said due to recent
investments double the number of illegal
guns were seized last year as the year
before gun rights advocates say the new
law won't help with the problem of
illegal guns while gun control advocates
think monday's announcement is a big
step forward but not far enough
that the problems
associated with bullets flying in the
streets of our urban and rural
communities
have
virtually nothing to do with
legal
law-abiding gun owners taking their
firearms to and from shooting ranges
this looks a lot more political than it
looks to be about public safety i think
that is a strong decision that has been
made today
and i'm very happy they are considering
a federal law on end guns and that's a
big progress
whether this legislation passes the
house and the senate and becomes law
remains to be seen one bill already died
well the liberals are hoping it does
pass and their promises can come into
force by the fall neetu all right
abigail beeman in ottawa tonight thanks
abigail
in uvalde texas families are beginning
the heart-wrenching task of saying
goodbye to their loved ones as the first
of 21 funerals are set to begin as these
children and teachers are laid to rest
many questions remain unanswered and the
anger over why this keeps happening
intensifies heather urex west reports
from uvalde
there are just two funeral homes in all
of uvalde texas and 21 funerals ahead on
monday the family and friends of amarie
joe garza filed in for her visitation
the little girl who died trying to dial
9-1-1
on a phone she had received for her 10th
birthday i can't sleep
i can't sleep with poor babies you know
i have a 10 year old daughter and it's
just horrible the way has been going
we're the only country in the planet
that has school shootings massive school
shootings
at two memorials set up for the victims
mourners continue to arrive many have
driven hours to pay their respects here
heartbroken as if these children had
been their own
as a mother
i felt like i needed to be here
and show
people that we care for them you send
the kids to school and that's the safest
place that you think that they are and
they're not not anymore
after meeting with the grieving families
for nearly four hours sunday u.s
president joe biden expressed hope that
this time this tragedy could finally
compel lawmakers to change the country's
gun laws i think things have gotten so
bad
that everybody is getting more action
while congress has so far remained
deadlocked on gun control last week a
bipartisan group of senators began
informally discussing the issue in a bid
to find new consensus on items like
universal background checks or red flag
legislation that could allow police to
take guns from people who are deemed a
threat
there are a lot of states that have red
flag laws i would support a grant
program to help the states that choose
to go down that road i will not support
a federal red flag law while lawmakers
continue talks this community still has
such a long and painful road ahead the
first of those 21 funerals will begin
here on tuesday as friends and family
say goodbye to emery joe garza and her
classmate mai to rodriguez little girls
who will be forever 10.
nitu heather urex west in uvalde texas
thanks heather
the battle for eastern ukraine continues
coming up fierce fighting erupts as
russian troops enter a key city
plus the murder of a popular punjabi
singer who rose to stardom in canada
sparks anger
an intense battle is going on in
ukraine's dawn bass tonight as russian
forces advance pushing into the
strategic city of severo donetsk in the
eastern luhansk region
russian military vehicles carrying
rocket launchers have been spotted
heading towards that city as putin's
military has been concentrating their
offensive in that area the governor of
luhansk says the fighting for the city
is fierce and the situation is difficult
and a french journalist covering the war
has been killed in seville donetsk after
being hit by shrapnel from a russian
airstrike frederique leclaire emoth was
seated in an armored vehicle covering an
emergency evacuation operation to get as
many ukrainians out as possible when the
strike happened
as ukraine calls for more weapons to aid
its front-line resistance today the u.s
confirmed long-range rocket systems are
close to being sent to ukraine to fend
off russian forces in brussels european
union leaders are working on a sixth
round of sanctions to hit the russian
economy but are struggling to agree on a
proposed ban on russian oil imports
the u.s has already turned off the taps
to russian oil imports but the block is
the biggest buyer of russian crude which
made up 27 percent of europe's oil
imports in 2021 an agreement is being
held up by hungary which relies heavily
on russian crude
the killing of punjabi hip-hop star
sidhu musayala has made waves in his
home country of india and in ontario
where he rose to international stardom
shivdeep singh siddu and two others were
shot in their vehicle on sunday in
punjab state india where he's from and
he later died in hospital the artist
immigrated to brampton ontario in 2016
as an international student and garnered
a huge following in canada where many of
his fans are now in mourning
i can't
you know
i really
can't express my
sadness for him he was my favorite
singer in four years his growth was from
this to this like he was a legend like
siddhu muse always put on for his
adopted city rapping about brampton
toronto and even canada as for who
killed him police in india say they're
investigating the targeted shooting and
are looking into a potential canadian
gang link
ahead political promises to stop kids in
foster care from becoming commodities
in the aftermath of last saturday's
powerful storm more than 15 thousand
homes and businesses in eastern ontario
are still in the dark crews have been
working around the clock to restore
service but in some places they're
facing dangerous tangles of downed trees
and utility wires power has been
restored to more than 900 thousand
customers since the may 21st storm that
killed 11 people nine of those deaths
were caused by falling trees
three days ahead of ontario's provincial
election two of the party leaders are
vowing to end for-profit group homes and
foster care agencies after a scathing
investigation by global news and aptn
youth in care said they were neglected
mistreated and repeatedly physically
restrained by workers without cause
carolyn jarvis was part of the
investigative team that worked on this
project for a year and joins us with
more carolyn
nithu we received an outpouring of
response to our investigation from right
across the country people who say they
too were victims of a broken child
welfare system that left them scarred
and traumatized some experts suggest one
of the reasons why the system is failing
is because private for-profit operators
might be putting money ahead of the best
interests of kids the child welfare
system shouldn't be a profit a profit
making endeavor it just shouldn't the
leader of the ontario ndp vowing to
remove for-profit group home and foster
care operators from the system if
elected the fact that kids are not
getting enough food that they're being
restrained that they're not getting the
health care services they need while
some company reaps the profits off of
that completely unacceptable a global
news aptn investigation analyzed more
than 10 000 serious occurrence reports
from the child welfare system in ontario
from a one-year period and found an
alarmingly high number of incidents at
some foster care and group homes
including deaths injuries missing kids
and the use of restraints
and while private operators only make up
25 percent of beds in the system they
account for 55 percent of all serious
occurrence reports in group homes and
foster care homes including 83 percent
of all physical restraints the
for-profit sector should not exist
advocates for young people in care say
they've known for a long time how bad
things really are this has been a
long-standing issue that we knew about
on the ground i grew up in the child
welfare system myself and this is it's
about time that this is in the spotlight
now the leader of the ontario greens
echoed the call to end for-profit group
home and foster care while the ontario
liberals did not saying oversight of the
system needs to be reviewed as far as
i'm concerned it's unacceptable ontario
pc leader doug ford also sidestepped the
issue of for-profit care vowing instead
to increase inspections
and admitting the province needs to do
better we're going to make sure myself
personally i'm going to be on this
right
as we have been but right after the
election that's going to be one of my
key focuses the ontario government is in
the middle of a multi-year child welfare
redesign but there is no indication that
reform will eliminate for-profit care
neethu
thanks carolyn
britton prepares to party next the royal
celebrations ahead for the queen's
historic anniversary
that is the world's most famous painting
the mona lisa by leonardo da vinci being
vandalized by a man disguised as a woman
in a wheelchair wearing a wig he gave
security the slip by faking the
disability and managed to smear a cream
cake on the glass casing in what appears
to be a climate protest the mona lisa
wasn't harmed but the painting did need
a good wipe down before the next crowd
arrived the man has been taken into
police custody
to the u.k now where the final
preparations are underway for the
country's days-long celebration of queen
elizabeth's platinum jubilee marking her
70 year reign as monarch redmond shannon
looks at the pomp and pageantry ahead
and why they aren't exactly going
according to plan
a special weekend an event 70 years in
the making
is almost here the finishing touches on
preparations for the queen's platinum
jubilee already a spectacle for tourists
and locals alike the work that's been
done and seeing the preparation has been
really incredible to see it looks
fantastic
it all begins thursday with the trooping
of the color the queen's official
birthday parade
with the royal family set to appear
together on the balcony of buckingham
palace culminating in a jubilee pageant
on sunday afternoon involving 10 000
people she's been 70 years you know
reign and you know in over a thousand
years of monarchy we've never had a
platinum jubilee and it's probably
potentially going to be the last last
one you'll see so it's exceptionally
important the busy schedule of events
may prove a little too taxing for the
queen given her age and recent health
issues one british news report says it's
unlikely she will now attend the
prestigious epsom derby horse race on
saturday covet 19 is affecting events
too friday's thanksgiving service will
not involve the church of england's most
senior bishop the archbishop of
canterbury after he tested positive for
the virus amidst the pageantry and
ceremony there will be thousands of
community events too the perfect excuse
for a celebration after two difficult
years of pandemic
cities and villages across the uk and
commonwealth will light commemorative
beacons including one outside ottawa
city hall a tradition that began for
queen victoria's diamond jubilee in 1897
and some 16 000 street parties are
expected to take place including some in
canada too stores in britain reporting a
jump in the sales of flags and party
supplies it's good for the country
considering what we've had to put up
with the last few years i think we
should all be out celebrating and making
a big big deal out of it really
even the queen's favorite pups are
getting into party mode too
customers at this corgi cafe like royal
lovers around the world ready to lap it
all up redmond shannon global news
london
pacino they call that and that is global
national for this monday i'm nitu garcia
tonight's your canada is a stunning
sunset over asuyas in bc's okanagan
valley don't forget to send your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching have a great night
[Music]
you